[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouf c'est une société qui cherche à
développer l'usagé du vélo pour offrir
une alternative crédible à la voiture
personnelle ou pour ça on est parti du
principe qu'il faut faciliter le
déploiement des services de vélos
électriques partager et donc on a vu des
modèles très intéressant arrivé depuis
un peu plus d'un an et demi avec des
vélos sans station c'est un modèle qui
est intéressant par la rapidité de
déploiement mais qui créent du désordre
dans les villes donc chez ouvre on a
inventé un nouveau type de stationnement
qui fonctionnent comme les caddies de
supermarché il ya une première borne
convient vissé dans le sol
et puis ensuite chaque vélo s'accroche
au vélo précédent le premier vélo
s'accrochant la borne
ça nous permet de mettre quatre vélos au
m donc c'est une solution qui est très
compact en étant à la fois très léger en
termes d'infrastructures puisqu'on a
juste cette première borne à venir
glisser dans le sol ça nous permet de
lancer facilement sans demander d'argent
à la collectivité c'est nous qui
supportant le coût de l'installation de
ces stations et d'autre une seule
station pour structurer le parking dans
les lieux danse ça chante dans les lieux
moins dense sur lesquels on peut se
permettre de garer les vélos sans
station on va le permettre
et c'est via l'application mobile qu'on
va explique à l'utilisateur quand est-ce
qu'il doit remettre le vélo en station
quand est ce qui peut laisser le vélo
hors stations et si ça ça génère du
désordre de manière évolutive on pourra
venir
introduire de nouvelles stations pour
structurer le parking on a choisi le
plateau de saclay pour plusieurs raisons
la première d'entre elles c'est la
proximité géographique avec notre siège
social qui est basée à vendre la seconde
c'est que c'est un territoire qui
présente une grande diversité d'usagés
puisqu'il ya des entreprises
les écoles des collectivités donc on a
on a tous types d'utilisateurs ce qui
nous intéresse évidemment pour une phase
de test et puis enfin c'est un
territoire qui cherche à gagner en
visibilité qui se développe sur lequel
il ya un manque de solutions de mobilité
donc il nous paraissait pertinent
adressé comme le lancement produit
l'assistance électrique est quand même
un atout tout à fait appréciable pour
pour les gens qui viennent travailler
donc pas forcément sportif et qui
souhaitent accéder au plateau de sacrée
d'une manière un peu plus durable que
parler par les véhicules
donc moi je le teste depuis quelques
jours on découvre un petit peu le
plateau aussi d'une autre façon donc moi
je connais très bien le plateau est là
le fait de le parcourir à vélo ça fait
découvrir des voilà des choses type de
nouvelles des points de vue un petit peu
différent et tout ça dans d'excellentes
conditions
cette phase d'expérimentation condé fois
sur le plateau de saclay donc avec 200
vélos à peu près 12 stations qui sont
déployées auprès de grandes entreprises
comme thales le cea l'onera des écoles
comme centrale supélec va nous permettre
d'accumuler des retours utilisateurs
d'améliorer le produit de mettre en
place nos process ceci pendant toute une
durée de cinq mois suite à quoi nous
pourrons travailler sur notre lancement
commercial dans le courant de l'année
[Musique]